[Music]
all right welcome back I'm always
tickled pink to find new ways to go
green and that's why I'm so excited that
our show is teaming up with Cascade to
share how we can all be a little more
sustainable in the kitchen year round
now here with tips is our resident green
Guru who also happened to be one of
people Magazine's 50 Most Beautiful in
1999. it's my dear friend Danny CEO
I'm now running to the Top Trail again
you're so hot so take it away what's
first what do we get to like here's a
good do just one thing so old sponges
like what do we do with them normally
you throw them away well sponges are
absorbent so what you can do is cut them
up into little squares with a pair of
scissors it can be smaller about this
size too and because they absorb water
guys what I like to do is I mix it in
with potting soil with your household
plants and you just sprinkle it in a pot
just like this you stick it in what
happens is when you water your plants
then the excess water goes into the
sponges and if you forget to water your
plants it releases moisture back into
plants to keep them alive
all right how easy is that that's so
easy sponges water okay I love pickles
do you love pickles I love pickles the
pickle brine what do you do with the old
pickle brand a lot of us just pour it
down the drain oh it smells so good it's
uh well don't drink it I mean you could
drink it if you wanted to but it's very
acidic there's a lot of vinegar you know
I want to drink it add instead of
drinking it drew how about pouring it
into this bottle because we're making an
organic and completely natural weed
killer
so you take this and spray it like where
there's weeds in the driveway you're not
using chemicals because it's so acidic
and full of all these things that plants
hate it dries them out naturally and
you've had to use your old pickle brine
I love that
how cute is that it's awesome I mean I'm
gonna be like spraying it in my mouth
but yeah I love this pickle juice also
like natural and tame ways of you know
managing the environment so this is
brilliant I would have never known
otherwise and we all have it and we got
one more thing what let's go over here
so so Drew right here we have a ton of
glass bottles okay which are wonderful
for the environment but why are there so
many well they're representational so
Drew I want to tell you a fact did you
know that using the dishwasher could
actually save water think about this if
you hand wash dishes with a running top
for approximately 11 minutes a day you
can use up to 24 gallons of water right
there that's 24 gallons but one this is
24 gallons but one load of dishes and an
energy STAR certified dishwasher uses
only four gallons of water per cycle it
could save almost 20 gallons of water
so
I'm so glad you're clarifying this
because I definitely grew up believing
that the dishwasher took more water than
hand washing so this is easier it's more
convenient and by running your energy
STAR certified dishwasher every night
with Cascade Platinum even a small load
you can save up to a hundred and thirty
dollars on your energy bill every single
year well who wouldn't want to do that
is that amazing
easier easier oh my God I was doing all
that works because I thought it was the
right thing to do it turns out I can do
less work and save more water yep well
I'm forever changed yes that's what I
said I met you Danny You Always Forever
change me you really are my hero Danny
I'm just glad that we've been brought
together because I'm like glued to you
the feeling is very very mutual you know
that Danny well thank you for
eliminating us we'll be right back
thank you
[Music]